La República Popular China es un país que
aspira a rivalizar con los mismísimos Estados
Unidos.
Un país que durante las últimas décadas
ha experimentado un crecimiento nachovidaliano
y que se ha convertido, ni más ni menos que,
en la gran fábrica del mundo.
¡Pero no solo hablamos de economía!
Ahora China también quiere su papel político.
Pensadlo así: ¿Quién conocía a los anteriores
presidentes de China?
¿Os suena Hu Jintao?
Seguramente no.
Sin embargo, Xi Jinping es omnipresente en
los medios de comunicación.
No importa si hablamos de Ucrania, de Irán,
de Venezuela, de Brasil o del Pacífico Sur.
Este país no para de protagonizar grandes
titulares que casi siempre tienen un denominador
común
La ambición de extender lo antes posible
su influencia por todo el mundo.
Son muchos los planes que Pekín ha trazado
para conseguir este objetivo.
Pero hasta ahora prácticamente todos ellos
han tenido siempre un ingrediente principal:
inversión, inversión y más inversión.
Pero todo eso ya lo sabéis.
Lo importante viene ahora, ahora de repente
las cosas podrían estar empezando a cambiar.
¿Por qué?
Pues básicamente porque la economía china
no atraviesa su mejor momento: Tienen una
burbuja inmobiliaria a punto de estallar.
Las empresas extranjeras cada vez desconfían
más de este país y…
el crecimiento de su PIB ya no es lo que era.
Cierto, este año puede parecer que están
remontando, pero esto se debe a la reapertura
del país tras su política de Covid 0.
Sin embargo, en el vídeo de hoy vamos a centrarnos
en un aspecto muy concreto de China ¿Recordáis
la Nueva Ruta de la Seda?
¿El proyecto Belt and Road?
Se trata de uno de los proyectos de infraestructura
más ambiciosos de la historia y la gran apuesta
de Xi Jimping.
Se anunció a bombo y platillo en 2013, es
decir, hace ya 10 años.
Y la pregunta es: ¿Está funcionando?
¿De verdad China puede recuperar todos los
miles de millones que han invertido en rescatar
tantos países?
¿O hablamos del inicio de un monumental fracaso?
Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
Arranquemos.
Si sois veteranos seguidores de VisualPolitik
ya conocéis de sobra lo que es la Nueva Ruta
de la Seda.
Para quien no lo conozca, os hago un resumen:
durante los últimos años, Pekín ha invertido
y planeado invertir una auténtica fortuna
en construir todo tipo de infraestructuras:
puertos, carreteras y puentes por todo el
mundo ¿El objetivo?
Extender sus tentáculos por el resto del
mundo y convertirse en el epicentro de la
economía mundial ¡Casi nada!
Hablamos de un catálogo de proyectos entre
los que se encuentran obras faraónicas como
esta.
N1(Pakistán aprueba una mejora ferroviaria
por valor de 6.800 millones de dólares.
El proyecto forma parte del multimillonario
acuerdo del Corredor Económico China-Pakistán
(CPEC).
China tiene previsto destinar 60.000 millones
de dólares a proyectos de infraestructuras
en Pakistán.
Railway-technology)
N2(China estudia un tren bala de 7.000 km
para conectar Pekín y Moscú.
The Hindu)
Esta es una gigantesca apuesta, toda una megalomanía
con la que Xi Jinping quiere que China recupere
la grandeza del antiguo y poderoso Imperio
Chino.
Para que os hagáis una idea, entre el año
130 AC y 1450 DC, la ruta de la seda se posicionó
como una de las rutas comerciales más importantes
de todo el mundo.
El flujo de mercancías hacia y desde China
llegó a condicionar la geopolítica del momento.
La vieja ruta de la seda impulso la diplomacia,
extendió religiones y benefició y promovió
la expansión del Imperio Romano, el Imperio
Bizantino, el Imperio Persa Sasánida, el
Imperio Kushan y la dinastía Tang en la propia
China.
Sin embargo…
toda gran historia tiene un gran final.
(Hacía principios del siglo XV el Imperio
Otomano boicoteó el comercio con occidente,
lo que provocó el cierre de buena parte de
todas las arterias comerciales que formaban
la histórica ruta de la seda.
Esa circunstancia obligó a las emergentes
potencias europeas a buscar nuevos caminos
para llegar a Asia.
¿Recordáis que, por ejemplo, Cristóbal
Colon llegó a las Américas buscando una
nueva ruta hacia las Indias?
Pues ahora ya sabéis el porqué.)
Eso sí, cuando Europa descubrió América…
Todo cambio.
De repente, el Atlántico se puso de moda
y la Ruta de la Seda perdió toda su importancia.
Sin embargo, en 2013, Xi Jinping decidió
sacarla de sus cenizas.
El gigante chino regresaba a la escena mundial
tras siglos de letargo ¿Pero cuál es el
plan de Xi Jinping exactamente?
Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
(T1: DE LA DISCRECIÓN AL GIGANTISMO)
La nueva Ruta de la Seda se ha posicionado
como la punta de lanza del nuevo expansionismo
chino.
Sin embargo, el origen de esta idea fue totalmente
diferente.
El proyecto nació de forma muy acotada, como
una vía para impulsar el comercio inter-asiático.
Fijaos.
N3(7 de septiembre de 2013: China propone
la recuperación de la Ruta de la Seda en
una visita a Asia Central.
El País)
C1(“Con el fin de reforzar los lazos económicos
y la cooperación, y ampliar el espacio de
desarrollo de los países de Eurasia, podemos
aplicar un nuevo modelo al crear el corredor
económico de la Ruta de la Seda.
Xi Jinping)
El líder chino hizo la primera mención a
este plan en medio de una agenda comercial
con Kazajistán y con Indonesia.
Por eso, el plan “nació” con dos partes:
la nueva ruta terrestre y la ruta marítima,
el collar de perlas.
En cualquier caso, el proyecto se limitaba
a iniciativas muy concretas y limitadas para
favorecer el comercio.
Sin embargo, el interés que automáticamente
despertó en muchos países hizo que Pekín
se diera cuenta del enorme potencial que tenía
esta apuesta: el plan parecía sencillo de
sacar adelante, daba trabajo a empresas chinas
y reforzaba el comercio con este país.
¡Pero no sólo eso!
Para un montón de países, este proyecto
era una oportunidad para conseguir dinero
de China.
Vamos, que enseguida se formó una cola de
gobiernos dispuestos a poner la alfombra roja
al capital chino.
Y, por eso, en 2017, Xi Jinping escaló la
apuesta.
De repente, ya no era algo limitado a Asia
sino a todo el mundo.
Abrió 6 grandes corredores y lo describió
como “el proyecto del siglo”.
(Desde entonces los proyectos se han multiplicado
para construir sobre todo infraestructuras
de transporte, energía y telecomunicaciones,
aunque también se contemplan hospitales,
centros educativos y otros proyectos de corte
más social.
En todos los casos, China financia las obras
a cambio de quela construcción, por regla
general, y en ocasiones también la gestión
recaiga en empresas chinas y los países receptores
sean más receptivos a la política exterior
del gigante asiático, por ejemplo, en lo
que respecta a los choques con Taiwán o Estados
Unidos)
¿Queréis un ejemplo?
Os doy un ejemplo.
Energía.
China ha financiado o esta financiando 44
proyectos para construir centrales de carbón.
También están construyendo miles de kilómetros
de carreteras y ferrocarriles.
Y la pregunta es ¿Qué países necesitan
estas inversiones?
¿Quiénes necesitan fuentes de energía convencionales
o infraestructuras?
Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
(T2: DIME CON QUIÉN ANDAS Y TE DIRÉ QUIEN
ERES)
Aquí viene un dato clave para Pekín: Casi
la mitad de los países que forman parte de
esta iniciativa son países de ingresos bajos.
Es decir, qué gran parte de las economías
en vías de desarrollo están subidas en este
barco.
Por ejemplo, 43 países del África Subsahariana
se han sumado a este proyecto.
¿Y por qué esto es importante?
Pues porque hablamos de países - y sobre
todo de gobiernos - con relativamente pocos
recursos que pueden tener muy difícil acceder
al capital para financiar grandes proyectos.
Y justo ahí es dónde entra lo que llamamos
la “diplomacia sugar daddy”.
¿Qué occidente no te da el dinero?
No te preocupes, Papi Xi Jinping se encarga
de todo ¿Y qué pide a cambio?
Tu lealtad: tanto política como económica.
Esta es básicamente la idea: Os ayudamos
a financiar vuestro desarrollo y a cambio
para todos vosotros, Pekín se convertirá
en la gran referencia política del mundo.
Por ejemplo, ¿Qué la ONU busca condenar
a China por la toma de Hong Kong o la persecución
de los Uigures - de lo que ya os hemos hablado
ampliamente en VisualPolitik?
No hay problema, No hay problema: Papi Xi
Jinping tiene sugar babies por todas partes.
(Fijaos, en 2020, cuando China sacó la Ley
de Seguridad Nacional en Hong Kong,
de los 53 países qu e firmaron una declaración
de apoyo a China en el Consejo de Derechos
Humanos de la ONU 25 eran africanos.
Y otros 3 grandes países: Nigeria, Sudáfrica
y Kenia, aunque no la secundaron, tampoco
se sumaron a las críticas contra Pekín.
Es lo que muchos han venido a denominar como
la estrategia de la Trampa de la Deuda, esto
es, China promueve que estos países se endeuden
hasta el cuello para que así se conviertan
en estados completamente dependientes.
Prácticamente vasallos.
Sea como sea, así es como luce actualmente
el mapa de la nueva Ruta de la Seda.
China ya cuenta con la adhesión de países
que representan más de un tercio de toda
la economía mundial.
Atentos a este mapa)
Aunque eso sí, un apunte importante: últimamente
la colaboración de muchos de los países
europeos en peligro.
¿Por qué?
Pues, en Not News ya os hemos hablado recientemente
de la crisis política que China ha desatado
por su persecución contra Lituania.
Para estar al tanto no olvidéis suscribiros
a nuestra nueva newsletter gratuita: Notnews.com.
Os dejo el enlace en los comentarios.
Pero, no nos desviemos.
Hasta aquí todo pintaba muy bien: China ha
pactado sacar adelante inversiones conjuntas
con cBerca de 140 países.
140 países que ahora tienen mucha más relación
y mucha más dependencia de Pekín.
Y, ojo, que esto es quizás lo más importante
y revelador de toda esta historia:
Según el ranking de libertades políticas
y civiles de Freedom House, los países con
menor puntuación son los más propensos a
asociarse con China.
Ni más ni menos que dos terceras partes de
todos los socios de China en este macroproyecto
son países que puntúan muy bajo en este
ranking.
Dicho de otra forma: Pekín quiere formar
un bloque conformado por países que tienen
un patrón común: son relativamente pobres,
tienen pocas libertades civiles y sus sistema
democrático es débil o inexistente.
Por supuesto, aquí están embarcadas la inmensa
mayor parte de las dictaduras del mundo.
Para que os hagáis una idea, en el mundo
existen 57 países que están considerados
como autoritarios y “no libres”, es decir,
básicamente dictaduras bastante autoritarias
donde cosas como la libertad de expresión
o la libertad de prensa no están toleradas.
Pues bien, de estos 57 países, 52 participan
activamente en el macroproyecto de Xi Jinping.
Pensadlo así: cuanto menos democrático es
un país, más fácil es conseguir su lealtad
incondicional.
Basta con convencer a las élites gobernantes
y cubrirles de dinero y proyectos de vanidad
para ganarse su lealtad.
Esta es la clave de la diplomacia sugar daddy.
¡Y ya sé lo que estáis pensando!
Todo esto suena malvado y maquiavélico…
¡Pero funciona!
¿Estamos ante el plan definitivo de dominación
mund ial?
O…
¿Tal vez no?
Pues bien, han pasado un montón de años
desde que China decidiera convertirse en el
sugar daddy de la política internacional…
suficiente tiempo como para ver algunos resultados
¡Vamos a verlos!
(T3: LOS PRIMEROS PALOS EN LA RUEDA)
Si incluimos a la propia China, más de la
mitad del mundo está embarcada de una forma
u otra en este proyecto.
En este sentido, la apuesta de Pekín ha dado
resultado:
Casi todos los países en vías de desarrollo
tienen hoy lazos muchos más estrechos con
Pekín.
El problema es que no todos estos países
tienen sus finanzas en orden.
(Lo que se ha venido a conocer como la trampa
de la deuda ahora corre el riesgo de convertirse
en una especie de Boomerang para Pekín.
La política de crecer, crecer y crecer a
cualquier precio está empezando a dejar de
funcionar, dentro y fuera de China)
Ya os lo hemos dicho: la economía china no
atraviesa su mejor momento.
Atentos.
N4(Los estímulos económicos en China pueden
empeorar las distorsiones.
Reuters)
C2(“Las medidas de estímulo en infraestructuras
podrían elevar el crecimiento en el horizonte
proyectado, pero podrían conducir a una mayor
acumulación de desequilibrios y mala asignación
de capital, y, por lo tanto, provocar un crecimiento
más débil en el medio plazo” Estudio de
la OCDE sobre la economía china)
A partir del año 2016, las autoridades chinas
empezaron a hacer todo lo posible para reducir
el exceso de deuda que tenían, sobre todo,
las empresas públicas.
Sin embargo, la cosa no funcionó y en 2019
el panorama se empezó a complicar.
N5(En noviembre de 2020, una serie de impagos
de empresas estatales de alto perfil envió
ondas de choque al sistema financiero a través
del mercado de bonos corporativos de China
[...] En febrero de 2021, el Banco Popular
de China retiró la liquidez interbancaria,
lo que provocó un aumento significativo de
los tipos de interés.
BBVA Research)
Esto es algo que no se suele contar, pero
tanto los gobiernos regionales y municipales
como las propias empresas públicas de China
son completamente adictos a la deuda.
Están apalancados hasta el cuello.
Y de hecho, el volumen de deuda que ya acumula
la economía china es altísimo.
Sí, ser la fábrica del mundo y tener un
sector privado relativamente competitivo te
da ciertas ventajas, pero queridos amigos,
lo cierto es que las finanzas públicas en
China están cada vez en peor forma.
Y, ojo, porque aunque la deuda del gobierno
nacional sea aparentemente baja en las estadísticas
oficiales, el problema está camuflado en
los balances de las empresas públicas.
Y eso es algo que cada vez genera más preocupación.
Y no solo eso, sino que también está provocando
que ya no baste con tirar de deuda y gastar
más y más para cumplir con los objetivos
de crecimiento económico anules que fija
el gobierno
En parte, precisamente, por eso, el crecimiento
económico de China se está ralentizando
en los últimos años.
Y eso no es todo, desde 2018 el impago de
bonos corporativos ha crecido exponencialmente.
C3(“El principal problema de un rápido
aumento de la carga de la deuda corporativa,
incluso si son las empresas públicas las
que se endeudan: es que deben utilizarse cantidades
significativas de crédito nuevo para atender
el servicio de la deuda más antigua, por
lo que cada yuan de crédito nuevo ya no genera
la misma actividad económica que en el pasado.
Sombras que se ciernen: La campaña de desapalancamiento
de China.
Rhodium Group, abril de 2023)
El problema es tan grande, que para que os
hagáis una idea,los intereses que tienen
que pag ar la deuda emitida en China ya superan
ampliamente el crecimiento económico del
país.
Y, claro, si la economía crece menos, entonces
el peso de la deuda se incrementa, lo que
a su vez castiga el crecimiento y vuelta a
empezar.
Pero, vale, la pregunta es, pero Fonseca ¿Qué
demonios tiene que ver todo esto con la ruta
de la seda?
¿Es que acaso hemos perdido la cabeza y hemos
cambiado de repente de tema?
Pues evidentemente no.
El problema es que en la última década China
ha sostenido su crecimiento económico a base
de endeudarse más y más y más.
Es decir, de sacar adelante enormes macroproyectos
que han creado toda una burbuja de inversión
en el país que ahora no está generando los
beneficios esperados.
Todo lo contrario, ahora hay que empezar a
pagar la fiesta.
¿Y sabéis qué?
Eso es algo muy parecido a lo que ya está
ocurriendo en muchos de los países que sumaron
alegremente a la nueva ruta de la seda.
Prestad mucha, pero que muchísima atención.
(T4: CRÍA CUERVOS Y TE SACARÁN LOS OJOS)
Con la Nueva Ruta de la Seda, o como se conoce
formalmente el plan “One Road, One Belt”
en marcha, el dinero comenzó a fluir a lo
grande.
China envió un enorme océano de dólares.
¿El problema?
Que, cuando se trata de recuperar esas deudas,
sólo esta llegando un riachuelo.
En otras palabras que, muchos de los países
que recibieron el dinero chino ahora no pueden
cumplir con los pagos de la deuda que habían
acordado, lo que está obligado al gobierno
chino a rescatarlos.
Sí, sí, lo habéis oído bien, a rescatarlos.
Y, el problema es que la broma está saliendo
ya demasiado cara.
Según un reciente estudio elaborado por investigadores
de AidData, el Banco Mundial, la Escuela Kennedy
de Harvard y el Instituto Kiel para la Economía
Mundial, China ha tenido que rescatar casi
100 mil millones de dólares en deudas tan
solo entre los años 2019 y 2021.
En total, hablamos ya de 200.000 millones
de dólares en rescates a países como Angola,
Pakistan, Venezuela, Sri Lanka o Sudan.
Todos estos préstamos iban para construir
infraestructura.
Pero en países tan corruptos y tan pobres,
el dinero desaparece en sobornos y sobrecostes.
Vamos, que muchos de estos proyectos de infraestructuras
no han servido para construir nada que funcione.
Eso sí, más de un dictador se ha hecho de
oro con el dinero de Papi Xi Jinping.
Y no hablamos de uno o dos proyectos.
Atentos…
C4(“El 35% de la cartera de proyectos de
infraestructuras de la Iniciativa de la Franja
y la Ruta se ha enfrentado a graves problemas
de ejecución, como escándalos de corrupción,
violaciones laborales, riesgos medioambientales
y protestas públicas”.
Aidata, Banca en la Franja y la Ruta.)
Ahora bien, ¿Quiere decir esto que la nueva
Ruta de la Seda pasará a ser historia?
Pues pinta mal, pero por ahora lo único que
podemos decir es que hace aguas.
Claro que China podría hacer de tripas corazón.
(T5.
¿NO HAY MAL QUE POR BIEN NO VENGA?)
Por primera vez desde que arrancará el siglo
XXI, China se está enfrentando a una fuerte
desaceleración económica.
La burbuja de inversiones que ha creado dentro
y fuera de sus fronteras podría estar a punto
de estallar.
Sin embargo, un momento, la conclusión de
la investigación que hemos mencionado antes
tiene algo inquietante.
Según este estudio, la crisis actual de China
puede ser parte de su maduración competitiva
contra EE. UU.:
(Este estudio plantea literalmente lo siguiente:
“Observamos paralelismos históricos con
la época en que Estados Unidos inició su
ascenso como potencia financiera mundial,
especialmente en los años 30 y tras la Segunda
Guerra Mundial, cuando utilizó el sistema
financiero para proporcionar fondos de rescate
a países con grandes pasivos frente a bancos
y exportadores estadounidenses.
Con el tiempo, estas actividades ad hoc de
EE.UU. se convirtieron en un sistema probado
de gestión global de crisis.)
Es decir, que China podría aprender a cómo
lidiar con los problemas con sus inversiones
en estos países y desarrollar los mecanismos
necesarios para poder gestionarlas.
Eso podría ser una herramienta muy valiosa
para impulsar sus relaciones económicas y
financieras con todos estos estados.
Claro que hay muchas diferencias: Tras la
Segunda Guerra Mundial la economía de Estados
Unidos iba viento en popa, ahora no podemos
decir lo mismo con la China.
Y eso por no recordar que el régimen de Xi
Jinping es una dura dictadura.
Y si algo tienen claro los dictadores es que
no se pueden fiar muchos de los otros sátrapas,
por eso al final todos llevan su dinero a
Estados Unidos.
Sea como sea, lo cierto, es que la nueva Ruta
de la Seda se ha convertido en un enorme quebradero
de cabeza, otro más, para Pekín.
La pregunta ahora es, ¿Crees que China podrá
lidiar con todos estos problemas?
¿Puede terminar este macroproyecto convertido
en un enorme boquete presupuestario?
¿Es este el final del gran sueño de Xi Jinping?
Déjanos tus impresiones en los comentarios
y abramos debate.
Y ahora si este vídeo os ha resultado interesante
no olvidéis darle a like y suscribiros a
VisualPolitik si es que aún no lo habéis
hecho.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.